hey what's up Hannibal Burres we got
another episode of the handsome round
the podcast with Michi ha if you listen
to the PI's you heard me go there before
easy amazing funny dude from Chicago
check him out online and joke hustler
he also be and I sold fast was I saw the
fast oh it's a new festival that I'm
starting and it's on pretty short notice
it's a nice old Mississippi at this club
called the players palace and it's gonna
be a lot of fun and I may or may not be
getting a mural of Dennis Graham on the
club anyways go die so defense calm for
tickets it's gonna be a good time I sold
a man himself is performing all three
nights shout out she leaked Jenkins
hooking it up with that booking it was a
tough get but we were able to book I so
the man himself so here's the flyer look
at that check out our new merch collab
with Gillian Evelyn she's amazing
look at that next year
hope you fly it this [ __ ] right now
[Music]
[Music]
here's the episode
I wasn't there my father said I was dead
yeah I have real stethoscopes you'd
understand stethoscope you you wish I
wasn't dead I just went on a discovery
mission for 17 years
all right him burn him at the stake okay
you got dark so I was doing a lot of
which dating back then like if they
thought you did anything cool they would
burn you at the stake which is probably
some time to live in and be real smart
right imagine a new invention if it was
too good there's a little kid yeah yeah
well the status quo isn't good enough
for you
right we like square wheels what do you
be a round wheel he's of the devil
Barnum who thinks like that made a
square wheel it was a tough business
back there square wheel make it like
your whole family had to do it yeah
always square will make us and he wanted
to come [ __ ] on the family name like
that with round wheels some of the bids
got to die what about dragons lives with
people stop believing in dragons you
know to be like Oh what that was a job
back there okay what you say they had
big lizards back then and they might
have just switched the mobile you know
might have been drags already might have
just vanished in the air we don't know
about dragons for real we just I guess I
mean isn't that what a dragon basically
is as a [ __ ] pterodactyl
they finally goddamn they found bones
too goddamn lizard with wings and
they're like I used to be dragons and
it's just a goddamn pterodactyl he gave
them fire and yeah they said [ __ ] it
let's give him five I mean but would you
would you get close enough to know if it
breathes fire now if you saw a giant
pterodactyl coming down from the sky you
really wouldn't know it depends on the
body language I think science will
figure that one out by now but the thing
is mermaids
they
myth the mermaids came from what are
those [ __ ] things those are the worst
cities
yeah manatees they said that the manatee
thought that they were just because they
got like hips like women and then how
would they know but they [ __ ] manatee
are you telling me that they was
catching them and they said they would
see this thing swimming their curves
like a woman swimming around like a
shadow what what [ __ ] lease a little
bit see you get horny that's a kick-ass
make sense like a woman swimming all
thankfully you're like damn I'll [ __ ]
that man it's already wet yes yeah
that's what happened that's what
mermaids come from yeah they came they
like in the manatees in any one father
but they had to tell stories he like
this and I want to throw it back at our
[ __ ] you know they say you gotta let
you sit on a rock sinking for me to come
to her I came over there she had all
these fish laid out ate the fish I hate
to proceed you ended that Hey
[Music]
never been to China Charlotte let
remember 1-800 Colette and they will
competing against the other 100 800
competing company and they go on these
commercials and I would think what they
want for me to call my family my parents
[Music]
and I'm you can't who I can't roll the
hips on the war is I the girl she's at
Orion she look like a lion face but I
like lions
that's the cases I'm like Danny Glover
I don't go for this [ __ ] I rap offbeat a
little bit and I speak from the 80s cuz
I'm crazy and ice machine and guess
would kiss you Lena
ladies revered their eighties rattle
it's another episode enhance around the
podcast hey how's it going good
alright special guest and friend of show
friends in real life on a shelf Oh meet
y'all what up man I'm eligible beauty
haul and this is my pre RV voice okay
what I would like to do is sing to the
viewers if I can especially the ones
who's watching this podcast with their
underwear off all right come on come on
Toni trim job in you is Late Late yeah
although guestbookís you a guide no day
do you cut oh the internet but you feel
like they gotta have something better
[Music]
but you like to be with us out Yuto
[Music]
so we decided onto an advice episode
right yes we were Tony champ we sure do
okay let's get into these questions I'm
excited to do another advice that was
over wine yeah sleep mask on me and meet
yesterday yeah totally focused and Michi
has a incredibly unique perspective on
stuff but so don't you think of me how
do you think I have an incredibly unique
perspective I feel like with me and you
giving advice to strangers they're gonna
they gonna get a while I gotta say cuz
I've been driving with meet you a lot on
this tour and he's got great he's been
saying some cool [ __ ] [ __ ] we'll meet
yet he was right a lot of the times no
father
figured it out about myself boom okay
but no father I'll buy myself figured it
out how you shoot a gun pops you in here
okay you ready yeah really good hey I'm
about to have lunch with this like sort
of like well-known artist and like my
film and my school set it up for me and
I guess I just wanted to know if you
have anybody's feel like talking with
somebody who's like pretty big in the
field you want to be involved in but
also not like annoy him I don't know
thank you like that's a solid ask
questions that's a very solid question
first so you want me to go first cuz I'm
ready I want you to go first well my
approach would be if you're very serious
about you really like a for-real tee and
you really got to try to really be
afraid
yeah you got yeah I really try to be her
friend first cuz you need to know if she
can handle it at work
anyone jeopardize your job and then you
need to give it time to really be
something cuz you don't want to risk
working or exposing yourself as in
exposing yourself to your boss you know
you better be a regular date you know
but I'm just saying really just be a
friend first and the more over the line
she go for the more personal you know
get let it be natural and then that
happened like that but really discuss if
you really want to deal like that or if
y'all just gonna [ __ ] around and be at
work wait I think yeah yeah I think you
got the question I think so we can let's
cut that play it again you could take it
again so let me see if I understand it's
saying it's a woman that worked as his
boss and he want to get up with you know
how to get up with it right no you heard
that all wrong okay it could be the
mayor yeah no it was somebody he said
he's meeting with somebody that's uh
that's famous just like a top artist in
their field and me gee how the [ __ ] did
you pray I got confused I thought is
like you answered the question before I
even heard the question to have lunch
with this like sort of like well-known
artist and like my field and my school
set it up for me and I guess I just
wanted to know if you have anybody feel
like talking with somebody who's like
pretty big in the field you want to be
involved in also not like misinterpret
that yeah
and you want to be in a field as a
whatever it is and you want to have a
conversation with them
you know overwhelmed um and [ __ ]
creep on my I mean X I guess serious
questions and really take their time
very serious I know real professional
people really like when you take them
very serious and take the time series do
your research and know the things about
them and the questions you have make
sure they researched and really good
questions and not just dumbass regular
ask questions that everybody asks but
something that really benefits you and
really affects you because you like to
see your impact on people in real life
if you take time to give them advice so
yeah that's that's that's my answer
yeah I would say you know just ask ask
good questions because sometimes you
know people I know I when somebody asks
a good question it helps me process
different things that have happened whoa
whoa oh [ __ ] I never even thought of it
like that so it makes it kind of fun to
have the conversation and so don't it
also just kind of you know try to build
a good rapport for you don't don't don't
step out the gate just asking for stuff
right away or if you are asking for
something be reasonable if you do want
to make a professional connection figure
out a way to add value for them and just
you know I think what I've work would
have been they say hey hey what if what
can I do this for you and then it makes
it work good where sometimes strangers
just hit me up hey can you be on my
podcast in Dayton Ohio and for what what
what is this I mean I mean they're
taking the shooting they're shot but
still it's just I guess yeah you got to
be realistic but the better
better angle of use some pocket and say
hey we did we got this audio thing we
made of your podcast and this is a
little clip that we did maybe you could
post it up and then and then that builds
that for me cuz before that you're just
a stranger trying to book me on
something that has zero benefit to me
and isn't even in the place where I live
so through the internet you can kind of
like for example risco funk that he does
some remixes we've posted it so why risk
oh [ __ ] as a producer there's no fun
I've never met but he's just from one of
the podcast freestyles he's just made
one he made a remix with one of his
beats and it was hosted up and it was
that yeah and so then I started hitting
him up and said hey let's do it it
started paying risco to make remixes and
giving him the episodes ahead of time so
he could but that's but but that's
because he show proof of concept you
know and he brought something dope to
the table up top without me even knowing
what it wasn't hey I got these beats
yeah you wanted to like then isn't that
how you got kennedy - no I think Kennedy
reached out asking to do design yeah but
it happens organically like you know
like oh yeah I like your [ __ ] i [ __ ]
with you but you can't just be in there
with nothing than be like hey man you
won't put my mixtape out it's like okay
let's hear your links yeah I think got
[ __ ] but it's coming soon so yeah so I
think this especially since you I don't
know what feels I wonder if it's music
music I think it is visual yeah good
question and beat you but here's a
question for you Hannibal do it does it
turn you off when people like say you
meeting up with someone there's someone
that really respects you does it turn
you off they fan out too much it can he
it depends on the sort of energy of the
is it's tough to describe where isn't
that it's not really a
and dry type yeah yeah this is what it
is so if it's a business meeting and
then you know usually in those type of
meetings with you know people with me
they'll sit some pleasantry said up top
and then we get into the other stuff
we'll talk about what we're what we're
working on I'm mostly I like to talk
about you making new stuff and so yeah
just varies if the if that's too much of
the energy because you know you wonder
if it's gonna be that it turns into a
meet and greet well not even that while
working together consistently if it's
gonna be annoying I've had a problem
with women passing out I just flat-out
just touching me and falling oh yeah I
get that what you sound cold and you
know I do too much text because I don't
want anything like seeing it done but
now what is that overwhelming so they
really work the salts you somebody
passes that other side is that it's
often somebody's nose and it wakes them
up like how does that work is that like
real science so smelling salt
melon sauce definitely works yeah under
your nose and then you snap out of it
yeah I mean I don't know for everything
but I know I definitely smelled is
pretty strong I I can imagine it waking
me about myself so I need to wake up of
a player passing out at my nose creeping
salt then I woke up what
I'm alert what happened I was talking to
me CH next thing I know I'm grinding my
teeth
damn and I wake up off the floor yeah
yeah smelling salts in my nose and I'm
like nah more weight gods well I don't
hang with meats no more no ma'am broken
mystic pass out make me feel poor dad no
car got robbed money's out my pockets
looking like rabbit ears what the [ __ ]
is going on but I still got it
steal I still got me I still got my soul
yeah I'm still trying to fill this
little hole just yeah yeah we'll be the
best handsome Rambler with Hannibal
Buress gold medal that's all I got for
you II guess dang that's the worst huh
I was worried about what I didn't see
you next yeah Rob this is really this is
really for ladies pass it on pass it
down flip leo
pass it on pass it out yeah
pass it out so
[Music]
hey hey oh it's like we're having a
little silent alright next question here
we go alright so I got the job I'm just
wondering how to get people to leave me
the [ __ ] alone
I don't want to be anyone's friend and
it's this new like startup mentality
kind of thing where they have this like
drink the kool-aid college dorm like
style of office and I just want to go to
work do my job and leave and it's
pissing people off but I don't want to
know about their kids or that I don't
want to go do that make your custom mule
bar on the seventh floor I just want to
go there and then go home what do I do
how do you look busy how to get people
to [ __ ] off without them get mad about
it that's a good resting
[ __ ] face you know that you've heard
that yeah don't you know me no we just
me and Tony just sorry that was that
wasn't right that no that was suicide
that's the face you need what you need a
suicide face we just had a stewardess
there gave the most like I was terrified
for the flight because our thoughts on
buzzing a copy herself we just crashed
the plane by hand whole faces the doors
are to the left in emergency if you push
the doors you would be kicked out the
flight all right not the whole fight
[ __ ] ILS falls from the sky put your own
[Music]
like dude she had this look on her face
like she was about to cry I have video
I'll show you need that face at work you
need that at work first and then need to
keep all your conversations absolutely
crazy like well somebody say something
so you say my my man beats me and my dog
actually bikes me and every time I have
friends here at work and I just wanted
to really talk about everything in my
life you just make up [ __ ] and it's keep
just keep making a long term job you
don't just want to bring negative vibes
to the work environment all the time
your personal life that has nothing to
do with your job
so I started conversation to me kind of
say hey you know I'm really into serial
killers and I just look at him I'm not
just to see where Hannibal goes with
this cease cuz you don't to be bothered
[Music]
it's a start up yeah and so I don't know
how many early-stage startup office you
know what what level that that companies
that but if she's in a situation where
you talking about there's just 10 to 20
employees at a company you know I don't
know is that style a spot you know and
you don't enjoy that culture that you
might need to find another places or if
you're
is highly qualified and in demand in the
job market there's either bounce because
it seems like that's not going she seems
like a freelance that's a person I don't
you can't change who she is and started
not playing about the bottom line if you
productive or you produce it they pretty
much to keep you it's pretty much about
that it depends what she does with if
she's probably some texture if it some
texture or even if see somebody that's
one of the first twenty employees as the
boss I like her because I hate people
that work talking so personal especially
in I'm situation if we're not talking
about work what do we need to talk about
so I want to know who's so personal it
works well yeah maybe she's just about
to talk about that this is not on you as
a person it's just me trying to create
time for myself I want to talk about
your family with you I just want to do
my work if you have any work questions
I'm right here if not there you go over
to Susie's QB yeah I'll go down to that
goddamn Moscow Mule bar and get you
goddamn drank and leave me alone it's
better to have a weird face all the time
no it's not about your regular life just
make up stories about kids you may have
and it fell down the stairs dramatic
[ __ ] just caught up in your own lies and
then you your lies will come true and
now you live in a lie you can't do that
that's a person's eyes you do what you
want your personal life they don't
really know it's actually illegal for
them to action if you take a personal
day
it's your person today if I if my toilet
fell down instead of the day and I had
to take a person who day four and I
don't want to talk about it at work but
I tell you about it because I wanted to
tell you about it do you find that any
me now I have any kids that's on you
you shouldn't ask me
logic my getting executed on the vacuum
cleaner like I just watch the lizard eat
his own tail and she got shot she eyes
got a pacemaker so I really blew up and
it was just all over the front room we
had plastic it soaked through that the
whole family had to clean it up there's
not a service that a clean of your
grandma in your front room would let's
get herself on a new Hoover mm a cubicle
or my own I'd be like I'd be like hey
you guys look if she's that important
she could get what she wants right like
hey you know you think maybe I could
just get like a corner of the office or
maybe like my own whatever like you know
I'm great I'm good to work with everyone
but you know like I'd rather just focus
and if you're a boss and you really
respect her work ethic you'll you'll be
like all right cool yeah like here's
your little corner here's do your thing
and you probably look after you make
sure that you ain't getting [ __ ] with
you know also a boss also likes a good
story you're going in your bosses
obviously I told her about time I feel
down instead my leg my grandma gotta let
you die so huh
yeah you know I'm on a repo you'll be
like this you just love stories cause a
personal okay see because I'm in the
dark turn it turn it turn it
other way yeah what's add some follow-up
questions what what how many people work
at the company was her job and how much
does she have to interact with people so
you try not to get a fire I just trying
to make it happy happy meaningful a lot
of people that built for those type
medicals wet things just go really
extreme and crazy
I mean hypothetically like what if you
just started saying wow [ __ ] to people
in they face why just having no
expression naturally she don't naturally
like people and like talking to people
and the natural answer that is to put up
a defense and ask be mean or be
standoffish which is in your facial
expression any conversation but
obviously she's not that brazen to do
that because she called into a podcast
with that concern hey I get that the
truth we imagine what should she do she
don't know what you do that's my advice
alright my advice is not I say you need
to get here's what I you need to go get
your employees together get your
co-workers together and have a nice fun
trip to sky Zone everybody just you know
hop on some trampolines do some dunks
and do some flips and then you'll say
hey ain't no party don't stop we get
paid at the party we hear the balls over
there we drinking but we can't get drunk
I miss guys oh I do what I want cap my
sky song socks together so I don't
[Music]
broke my ankle but I'm back at it so you
wanna put a cast I said nah let's get
this [ __ ] crackin
hand me the vicodin and I'm headed back
out to the skies song do the dunk and I
cracked my skull and I fall down they
say you want to go to the hospital I
said nah it's just a skull fracture
let's just have some fun hit the skies
off practice go up but I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm at the sky Zone do this dump
behind the back do it behind the back
then my elbow came out of the left side
I'm like oh no they say that back into
your elbow socket I said nah just pop
and like it
I'm driving I'm in skies on no time to
stop and fun huh broke my leg they're on
that jump don't know no cast just put it
just grab some gum grab some gum around
my knee that's all that I need why miss
guys though everything is free yo go to
the skies on with my water cup and fill
it up with spray that's what I'm on
tonight during this list fall they say
you wanna go to hospital you ain't
gettin those limbs at all
I said everything is good I'm bout to go
on the trampoline they said what is
happening I said I don't know man
huh skies on sticking it skies on with
Paul Monroe's went up four thousand and
the brim just cause my nose now my face
is going out I'm bleeding all that
bleeding on all these children and my
name is Mark and I work next door I told
that [ __ ] all right I'll [ __ ]
you up I don't care if we give this
guy's on us going up there
that's why you broke your leg okay me
cut your nose little wrong
I set it up cuz I don't care I hate you
in this comes over there skies oh that's
a place I did it we have to work and I'm
winning getting fired
right here I'm a snitch I'm mark next
worksheet make super cool
I believe it uh you know I had it in a
movie to get the good person in the bad
person you needed a antagonist with that
protagonist so yeah go to sky Zone and
bond with your employees I think that's
a good I think that's a good employees
everyone together there's a worst
nightmares you gotta talk to one a rat
over they jump around man the air is
you're by yourself and they solo in the
air they got a everybody's don't flips
they're doing their own things she's
doing her own thing they high-five in
the air it's a good time I don't think
y'all get here I think I'll totally miss
her who point I don't like people she
works right next question and I want to
talk to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she doesn't thank you
skies on that man we should if I could
pitch that song the sky Zone I don't
know put that on the website skies I
think the insurance how do you go up a
Hannibal I just wanted to say first off
I really appreciate what y'all are doing
you guys brighten my day I listened to
you guys while I'm working I'm driving
around in my work truck and poppin locks
and making car keys
I'm a full time locksmith and one of my
things I wanted to ask them you know is
my creative time I don't have very much
time in my day on call 18 hours a day
for six days a week so thank you
my one day off is pretty much just doing
laundry and getting chores done but I
struggle with trying to do what I love
which is playing trombone and circuit
bending and doing a whole bunch of
random [ __ ] making little beats on my
computer but I can't really find the
time 100 set up the time throughout the
week yeah I just wanted to see you guys
speak on how you stay motivated with
what you do and when you're really tired
after you get home after a long day like
how you actually stay yeah how you
actually stay motivated and concerned
with what you're doing I also have a
follow-up question I'm 22 years old you
do a second and I'm worker right now
making family but I'm wondering what
your first step would be as a young
full-time worker to build some wealth
outside of just working you know making
a like a thousand a week or something
like that just how you would go about
building more wealth all right thank you
guys okay okay I like that question all
right the second question was the first
question no the first question is great
actually cuz I struggled with the first
question before well it's really who you
are like if you do something that really
makes you feel a certain way there's no
value you can really put it against that
I mean get enough money to pay your rent
or pay bills or whatever but neglecting
your act
two hearts passion that's it that's just
a choice you make you don't I mean it's
mentally unhealthy though but so to work
18 hours straight five six days a week
have one day off I mean it's quite
enjoying doing it it's not healthy for
you it sound like he's about to cry like
you think you are right now but it's
really killing you man you need to get
your trombone and write you a couple
blues songs about people losing a life I
kind of feel bad that these questions
are from April yeah we should have
called this person on the phone here you
know what's the guy who put the locks on
the things and wood was a magician to
get it off the faster I'm sorry I'm
tripping no no no like that you know
that's the company Matt like anyway he's
go ahead I'm sorry man all right cool
he's a lock master and that's what he
did he she's a locksmith locksmith a
lock master that's what is a genie man
well I just I think his hours are crazy
probably because people probably get
locked out at the dumbest times of the
night like it's probably like he
probably yeah I mean when you're locked
out of your apartment gonna be any time
from like 3:00 in the morning till
[ __ ] you know 3:00 p.m. I don't you
know it's like everybody gets locked out
all the time all during the day that's
what I call [ __ ] I know he got some
time to sit around
bring your [ __ ] he said he got a little
beat us he makes beats and [ __ ] what is
it to just get a little [ __ ] thing
like a like an organelle like that bring
it around with you have some headphones
[ __ ] around in that yeah stop being a
[ __ ] all right
that's what we say it's a lot of times
for us innate and you're working 18
hours if you get the strength to work 18
hours a day and be on Carl you can take
you
those hours and we're completely on your
art hey let me tell you something let me
tell you something I used to work for
outtie right and I was a I was a parcel
delivery guy I would deliver parts and I
give me a van what would you get the
parts of Tony Julia listen let me just
um I know your name on the street I'm
getting to a point here okay okay so
like they would give me parts and they
say I'd take him over here blah blah but
this is when they had the car phone and
sometimes like it is when we're map
questing and they had a car phone that's
how we communicated with each other and
the car phone it would ring a few times
and it would automatically answer that's
just the way it was that was probably
right so what I did I what I used to do
especially if I had a long drive like if
I had to go from like you know
Schaumburg all the way into like you
know the south side that delivers some
like a hood for a four I'll park my
[ __ ] car at the crib but I would
leave the radio on and then I go inside
and I'll you know [ __ ] around freestyle
a little bit deejay to myself make a
little mixtape
hop back in the van go drop the [ __ ] off
and I would leave the car running with
music blasting because if they did call
it would just sound like there's music
so when they're like why enchants the
farm be like oh I was blasting music I
hear you I was driving I was in traffic
so there's always a hustle to find
yourself some time to be creative is my
point
yeah locksmith thing we'll get to is
financial the locksmith thing brings me
to just my thoughts and philosophy on
house keys in general as someone who has
hired a locksmith I don't like how
confident they always are they get to my
place and just ambiguous pricing thing
and so it just really struck me over the
past few months that whenever I leave my
house with the keys and go further away
than 20 feet from the house with the
keys that's just that's all risk and no
reward in that action leaving the house
the keys the house keys should stay with
in
a one-block of the house hidden in a
place add worse or in a lockbox or
something kids no reason why they should
be at the restaurant or on a plane or in
a car with you going far away in your
home bulking up your pocket bag open up
pockets in just yours when you work yeah
backseat of movies make a noise when you
walk [ __ ] hurtin when you lean over
on it no he's right I mean if we have
thumbprint technology for our [ __ ]
goddamn phones why can't we just apply
it at the doors oh I mean I got dizzy at
my place in Chicago I did I had digital
keypads cuz I just works it's nice it's
nice and also make me feel like I'm on
some got the James Bond that [ __ ] that
sounds very cool no digging in your
pocket so you just press some stuff yeah
and I do it fast to make sure whoever
I'm with face recognition in hand
recognition to get it to his home read
it on ready that's why the thumbprint I
think that's what a thumbprint [ __ ] is
dope yes yeah boom so do you have the
face and hand you get the hand me yeah
it's a four digit code but then I'm
doing I'm upgrading soon today it's the
code it's only it's time sensitive codes
and it goes to Wi-Fi so there if I need
somebody to go by there for a certain
time they got this code your code is 2 2
to 2 from 2 p.m. to 22 yeah that's how
you got to do it and then that code
expires at 2:23 and if you try to use
that code at 223 i'ma see from the ring
camera and then I'm alert the local
goons and they don't come there and hit
you with 22
I'm on my way
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
slap your ass Hans we can we can run
this code afaik so their leaves please
did she walk you downstairs the code is
there damn animal got talked out on that
one he shot a lot of people you shot a
lot of people just came out to come out
of you who what but she was protecting a
space though like that was really in it
to be your corner yeah but your mother
Hannibal let's go back to like episode 2
when you were first talking about buying
a crib you said your instinct was what
it was my first property yeah yeah yeah
that was like it's about thinking about
a good myself like I'm mature enough now
and it's just kind of like if something
really happened for real good anything
is literally happening that you know and
and it's just kind of not wise almost I
mean anything is literally happening at
this point I mean that's my thing too
cuz a gun get it's like it's really a
spirit energy you put on you because it
just makes you feel so confident in and
everything I mean have you
the gun before I've had a gun when I was
a teenager and I remember the power
I remember being excited what's your
hook somebody 22:38 25 this 25 yeah just
enough just to you know just say I have
one and if I really got in trouble
walking
get somebody up off of you wasn't really
good no man sounds like judo lessons
hold on
let's yeah how many how long did you
have this gun for I was about four or
five years four or five years and how
many would you walk around like I say on
an average month 30 days how many days
would you walk out with the gun well you
become obsessed with the gun okay you
always know I said it's always should I
bring my gun with me today you know what
I mean and in his Kent County it's not a
good thing oh it's not a good thing
well my neighborhood was like a read a
really shot a lot of people in my
neighborhood all the time and a gun was
a status a gun was a way didn't let
people know use for real you know and
everybody didn't know but it was
everybody kind of didn't know but it was
a little more status thing to be ain't
you ever that you ever up the black ink
on anybody well yeah but it wasn't it
Martha
it was my well when I did join the game
for three days out of the true story
yeah and uh three days well yeah yeah
we're gonna beat you out right away
or actually I guess together you weren't
officially in the game cuz they got to
kick your ass in don't they yeah it was
one of the things around them all the
time I finally was like well you know it
counts so the story is real and it's
definitely things that happened but I
just I just when it comes to dumb crimes
I'm just not interested and that's why
they gave me pastors I was always man I
look right that's just stupid and older
people older oh geez around they would
be like yeah sure to get a little
something on them so he asked me to do
little stuff but I wasn't with nothing
that would make me go to jail it's just
stupid it to me but anyway I had to go
shoot it somebody I was my first
assignment and the first assignment yeah
yes assignment get right into it yeah
and so what what was this meeting like
where you were given the orders okay
they had everybody standing in groups
and you stand I waiting your assignment
with the people that's on your level
it's really like it's really like a real
company right now they the board meeting
over there they make the decision you
hate the decision you hope you don't get
picked for it they give you the task and
they send everybody to watch you to make
sure you do do it and that's where I saw
the stupidity cuz I'm like if I hit
somebody I got five witnesses here with
me that ran soon as I start shooting
your honor maintenance it's the dumbest
crime in the world but when I ain't I
ain't like so far over they hit it I had
to be almost hitting birds there was not
paying attention to what was happening
that was just that was my goal my goal
was just to do it but make sure I didn't
hit nobody so you were they were they
was they was on in our territory and
they were walking back and it was an
alleyway so I was maybe two or three
houses off the alley and they were
across the street walking the alley okay
so with the when the meeting when they
gave you the directive right they said
dude it was that was an immediate thing
those guys over there they two blocks
away you need to get on that or was it
as these immediate immediate yeah it was
immediate like therein we said needs
people to watch you you want to know
what happened when you come back come
back with the gun and let us know happy
oh see but for me I looked at it like
you know since I had a decent family
they want you to go to jail that way you
could be totally under control
are they system you go in there you got
a report to somebody else and they're
gonna see how tough you are if you're
not tough enough they're gonna you know
it's like gang training yeah you know I
mean and any condition you can call and
I'll be afraid of afraid of a jail but I
saw that in the first day like I was
like wow this is really so you mean I
gotta go with all these weaknesses it's
not how I want to do a real crime like
if I wanna do a crime is this serious
but don't they make the shorties do all
the dirty work anyways cuz they don't
get like locked up for life yeah that's
exactly what it is
it's training is you know you got people
watching you to make sure you know how
old are you 15 yeah in the neighborhood
that's why I'm always when I see a group
of like kids like that around that age
I'm [ __ ] scared man I'm like yo you
better be gene and make you sing and
drugs that'll make you mug yeah that's
that scary that's that scary ass young
mentality I can't I can't be around that
energy anymore yeah well you got what
I've learned though if you just have a
conversation with him I mean I like a
lot of kids haven't even had a
conversation and most things they know
are from a distance so you you develop
disrespect for those that just they're
only because they don't speak to you so
when I start talking to him I talk to
him like the kids and they immediately
second sentence turned into a kid
giggling roasting the same regular kid
stuff they remember that this is a lot
of it was forced on them just on being
born in a certain neighborhood and
trying to get to school every day
it's kids want to be kids man they don't
want to play like that's serious stuff
and when you immediately like once you
in and you already committed yourself to
it don't manage it it's a process
once you're there and it's too late you
have to put on a character just to live
or survive in that world so it's it's a
real serious thing man is crazy that's
why I try to do as much as I can
I haven't been in community as much the
last couple of years because uh I
realize gotta get you know a certain
level to really do something but uh it's
a process did this show just give real
deep huh I guess I mean my man went with
the without the with the mask on I'm in
a deep darkness you know my mind and the
things that really had me tossed and
torn in at night when I'm in the hood
cuz I live in my preference I love it
when you live at 60th n right off King
drivers will see my dress but I wanna
get robbed by you crazy [ __ ]
but it's right off a king Drive it's
right go watch the park I believe that's
the woodline neighborhood which is one
of the highest growing
profitable real estate areas in the
country Air Force magazine is like four
yeah man I was just trying to tell you
about a deer to ago you know but uh yeah
it's the truth they got a lot of new
stuff over there building but the
neighborhood has definitely changed a
lot but uh from my living in hoods all
these times I've just seen so many kids
there were favorite kids in the building
with me or whatever you know go down
that path or get shot or just stories
man 15 years with a a cake you know
nerves and crazy stories crazy stories
but all right you guys want go to the
next question here yeah man because uh
you know this goes back to stay what's
up Hannibal what's up Tony my question
is what is the best way to hustle and
grind while unemployed like what would
you do to make a couple quick bucks
so I don't know to fun you know man I
got you well from the time of my life
where the world has changed so much
between then and now the type of jobs or
the quick things that
I'm really different then you know I'm
talking like 2008 when I first moved to
New York so now is all types of [ __ ] man
don't ask me that [ __ ] I got 30 absolute
listen I got a good answer
I got an honest good answer good answer
all right I would say find like go to
Whole Foods look around see what white
people like right and then figure out
how to make that and make it a craft
thing right so you like make kombucha
right they figure out a dope-ass way to
make kombucha you make the best kombucha
and then you sell that [ __ ] you grow
your kombucha business because you could
charge whatever you want it's easy to
make all you need is sugar and tea to
make kombucha and ask OB that's all you
need or learn how to brew beer and make
craft beer and make the best goddamn
beer you possibly can and hone in on
that you could sell bottles and you get
a crazy return that's what I've say but
find out what white because white people
pay whatever so find out what white
people like and make that [ __ ] really
good or you can create a black woman
hair product any good black woman hair
product you gonna sell the black women
in white women cuz it's a good hair
product just is very specific though
it's not yeah you could really get a
thousand dollars per week or some [ __ ]
okay yeah
I mean Koreans do that I see that mm-hmm
my relatives that I've been in that
hustle yes and I see that yeah I agree
with you on that we don't know what he
is working capital would make Bo it's
very surprisingly easy to make it only
takes like a week to ferment yeah very
easy to make and white people love it or
everybody loves it but white people
particularly love it now he wanted a
side job something really that isn't
accident tell people today he really
doing some when he really doing
something else I heard it in his voice
it is a side job bad that [ __ ]
dirty man learn how to make kombucha is
my answer yeah we don't do it
[Music]
yeah here's what you need to do maybe
you can drive I don't know maybe you
could work with the city do some [ __ ]
with the Sanitation here's my advice I
think you know you know man you know
don't let Tony get just a lot of
different things out here there's a lot
of different there's a lot of different
things you got some money to start
yourself off borrow some but there's a
lot of good ideas out here you see how
folks are getting money Oh kind of ways
all types of ways it's why you gonna do
execute man don't hit us up with that
stupid ass [ __ ] do you know how to go
get money [ __ ] is simple man you ever do
something you know how to go get this
[ __ ] money man it's all people
get money do do a vape ASMR channel or
some [ __ ] driver be a kombucha salesman
[ __ ] do analytics for Instagram
fitness models there's lots of jobs out
here most of the easiest job out now
that you can really do then not go to
college for and just do you could be a
motivational speaker
those guys are jeans they just get up
and tell other people to do [ __ ] yeah
that's a great job hey one day I was
laying around doing it and I told myself
get up and I decided to tell other
people to get up and people say I need a
hit
slapping that's what I did that's it
everybody that's what I do that's what I
did I got up because I told myself to
get up and I tell you to get up and do
something but you know what it is
sometimes people don't tell they've
close friends to get up that's the thing
and that's why Tony Robbins is a
millionaire preaches preaches that's you
got to keep working
you got to keep trusting you got to keep
believing that is go read Steve Harvey a
is their reality show so you want to be
a preacher oh that's a great idea there
should be audition for that so you want
to be a priest
yeah see so you want to be a preacher I
think you could posted by Cedric the
Entertainer boom you think I could be
honestly you you think I could be a
genetic Church that makes a little sense
yeah I mean I got so many tattoos
no what shall preach a cadence don't ya
see cuz it gotta be I'm going off of you
know our experience together live shows
yeah and I back I said yo you need to be
aids and Funk Flex and you're like no
that's harder than that
[Laughter]
okay all right all right give us give us
some organ over there meet ya give us
some church some strange noise okay
listen
amen okay please no just keep it hold it
down let it go listen children of God my
name is Tony trim and I'm here to give
you or deliver a message
hmm everybody must get together yeah and
not kill each other anymore
yes let's all share the weed let's all
share out of the same 12-pack of beer
okay don't be selfish amen
have you got six pieces of steaks you
give forward to your fellow brother and
you eat the other two how's that sharing
is [ __ ] she's being contrary it's just a
mess
come on come on
so you change your tune on me how would
they do that is overheat that if you
don't know how to handle the heck of
that church you know that you need to be
drunk or David you know you see real
drugs real crackheads real thorough
change their life every send me with a
baby mama baby there and you will have
somebody that's what the Deacons got
strong hands they gotta really bless
people
the churches ran out as
oh yeah yeah at the sky and I hit my
head open
my ribs broke my ankle and I'm sick
right now in the
[Music]
[Music]
that's what I do
[Music]
[Music]
pull up the broken bones in my life in
the sky in the sky is suspended right
I thought you hip your back bone your
back won't slip your cranium correctly
is a sly stop and you ain't your
[ __ ] but you had to get that
had a good time skies on yes see
tomorrow zones good time tomorrow that's
great yeah ok next question next
question next question yeah let's do
this alright that's the last one guys so
let's make this let's make this a good
one Oh Johnny
she's got an advice question for you
here so I got my girlfriend and that'll
be been dating a couple years and she's
she just got accepted a new grad program
oh no no and you know she's moving out
there and she wants me to come with
somewhere right now that's a pretty
steady job here in Chicago okay and it
just you know it feels kind of tough she
wants to kind of like uproot her whole
life move out there zona and you know I
won't be very much and you know we got a
great thing going so what do you think I
should do here I'm 25 and do I choose
love or you know the security of having
a nice job when you know I'll shut up
and listen that's a tough one she
doesn't love you man come on obviously
hurt he got a good job and he's doing
really well together yeah did she want a
golfer just say I'm moving to Arizona
and make a choice like what sad though
okay maybe not hurt but he said he said
sounds probably I don't know I don't
think he sounded sad I think he's just
thinking about this situation I mean he
don't want to lose yours
hold on man mmm goddamn turn yeah I
don't think I think I I think he do is
hide his [ __ ] down there I think that's
part of it was a similar city I think he
wouldn't be as is Arizona if he I don't
even
this phone call happens if he says yeah
my girl is thinking about oh she's going
to grad school in New York I don't think
he I think he's like well you know
figure it out New York City baby you
know 20 but he's the middle of the
desert but yeah but but the job thing is
I mean that's pretty I mean if you've
got a great job and it's a good hustle
that's that's it that's why it's a tough
one for me making anybody choose over
their career over you is just that's us
I mean yeah that's my quite I'm sorry
well that's my answer always is like no
my career comes first yes I gotta you
know thing for one yeah thing is is he's
working what I mean what was she going
to grad school for what is her projected
income or job prospects after finishing
job school I'll get married that's hella
debt you take it on use out here getting
his money she's just taking on more debt
[Laughter]
he's like yeah but you got to look at
the bills man depending on the grad
school every way more than man and so uh
that's something to consider Arizona how
much you want to just go to Arizona 25 I
mean I don't know just time you got time
to bounce back yeah I mean 2025 you got
some time ago cuz grad school or
whatever those plans from get nothing's
guaranteed but is is it even that
necessary is it or you can why can't you
just if you're making enough money why
can't you just do the long-distance
thing and yeah
and really bad and you probably need
time to figure it out before you
actually get married that would be
actually a perfect summer or next two
years of my life to have a very serious
long I know long distance is not
realistic but if they truly you know
what it's a test if it's truly meant to
be they can make it through this
struggle yeah 25 I was a horny back
don't be grad school Rd she's gonna be
spinning intense hours long hours with
yeah she's gonna be going to parties
with kegs and jungle juice that's why
students are more on the mellow side not
a dose it depends though is she going to
tempeh she gonna Arizona State yeah
that's a party school but I think that's
a serious question is it is it worth all
that exactly have you talked about that
gila family they take us to the desert
fam get a comparable job out there is
not did hang out in the shot
pitchfork bro get out there and get it
so I can get your florescent shades get
your wife beater and prep for
Lollapalooza 2020 yeah headline by
headline but what Lollapalooza 2020 it's
me i headlining they put me on at 2:15
on a sunday and the sun is blistering
hot 98 degrees is camión doing my set
slow it back down so I catch it I'm on
the Lollapalooza stage this early but
everybody out there to see made they
burned it and everything is hurting I'm
trying to spit my flow it's too early
mothers feel sticking that the raptures
coach and his eight feet too and missus
I was eight years old and I got the
phlegm in my there goes a nice flimsy
blind wrap right there yeah wait a
minute fit I know you will
cuz all my flow is to show you us I'm
like showing up I kick it I'm like women
I did it wittingly golf old-ass
basketball player no football cuz I kick
it like I said like the French way when
you play football every day I wrapped
like a eighties wrapper cuz my brain is
slow it's like 80 years old grandpa get
some lyrics yeah alright alright
concerned you are about your people in
and you want to really fix their lives
with their questions that's nice that's
really nice thanks man you know we care
about our fans we care about the rambley
dolls this be such a good day guys yeah
this bit of fun this has been a fun tour
this is Charlotte we did we on an
interest in schedule cuz we did Sunday
through Thursday shows every night then
all Friday this is the grown man tour
Friday Saturday oh you got the weekend
off to church on Sunday yeah chill it
makes it more chill less yeah less
opportunities again into some [ __ ]
and the BISM back ass club all right
[Music]